first of all i have a lot
a lot of questions about coming to
america for the two of you but everyone
i've been interviewing recently i asked
the same
first two questions which are uh what tv
series would each of you love to guest
star on
i'll go all that nickelodeon because
that's just you know i always wanted to
be on that show
right now atlanta i want to be on
atlanta
yeah you would fit in so well by the way
um put me in put me in the office
okay what movie have you guys seen the
most
sleepy hollow my favorite movie
three billboards outside ebbing oh
really yeah i love me a small town crime
movie and i'm surprised
what's up it's so good so good good
uh so jumping into why i get to talk to
you guys today i would imagine
everybody and their brother wanted to be
in coming to america
be able to work with eddie murphy so i
am curious
for each of you how much did you pay to
be in the movie
um i only gave my uh my child
that was it you know just just my child
you know i had shares in
in tesla so i i gave those away yeah
bitcoins all of them but all all great
decisions that thing i have no regrets
me thanks
the thing about coming to america the
original movie is that it's
people love this film and i'm curious uh
and a lot of people might not realize
that it was
uh like the first time like an african
royal family was put on screen
it's a very early big like well i guess
what i'm curious for both of you is when
did you first
see the original film and what does it
actually mean to you
well again you know i was born when it
came out so i didn't see it like i was a
kid like eight or nine i would say and
uh
it was an instant love and an instant
appreciation
um i understood the thing about eddie
like eddie
resonates to everybody he's that amazing
so i got the movie immediately um
especially the jokes
and um it just it it's one of the
reasons why i wanted to do
film in the first place so it's
it's just up there with everything that
i aspire to do so to be a part of the
sequel
is simply just a humbling and it's a
dream man
i mean okay i was born in 1990 so it's
older than me
that's for sure um but i was pretty
young i know that
when i was in my teens obviously because
my dad used to play it
all the time it's only then that i got
to understand it but i think what i
remember the most and what i loved the
most was just like seeing
the african luxuriousness of it all you
know
and and how funny it was and and seeing
people in costume
it's so nostalgic in terms of just like
everybody
knowing where they were and who they
were watching it with
so it's it's it's unreal to be able to
be in the sequel right now
it's taken seriously too like a lot of
comedies back then especially black
comedies
were just joke machines you know but
this one was shot with such
gravity uh with the drama and the comedy
mix it was even looked like a film like
it looks beautiful still holds up
it's it's a it's a movie that still
holds up today um
and it being a black fairy tale just you
know again it's opened so many doors for
literally everything else that came
after it so yeah man i'm curious for
each of you what it was like first like
three days of filming
you know you're like you know you know
you got the part you know you're in the
movie
but like are you sitting there like
extra additional pressure on yourself
like
i cannot screw this up like i you know
being like a little more in your head
oh definitely i had to talk myself out
of it because it's such an
out of body experience you're supposed
to not geek out
that eddie murphy's walking on to said
you're supposed to not geek out
that arsenal is having a conversation
with you like this is normal
no it's not
[Laughter]
absolutely not so a lot of moments of
wanting to geek out and waiting to get
to your trailer
to be like oh my god oh my god and then
somebody knocking namzam
we're ready for you on set and you're
coming out normal again because these
are your colleagues right
be professional so it was but you know i
think one of the best things was just
how fun it was to be on set and how
everybody just had such
a great time no one had i mean you only
know
that they are iconic because they around
you and you can't believe this is your
life
but nobody had any kind of like
diva or like big presence or whatever
everyone just had this mutual
and beautiful respect for each other
there was so much happening behind the
scenes
and i hope you guys get to see it yes
there's a lot of nervousness
with the movie like this of this
magnitude it's it's yeah of course
i'd be lying if i said there wasn't but
there's you got cast members who
you know kind of just relieve a lot of
that anxiousness from you like
hanging out with him zamo and sharing a
lot of our thoughts
and you know what uh you know how how
we're feeling about this whole situation
made me feel like that much more
comfortable on kiki as well
uh and you know sherry like she was such
a mom on set she really just you know
the relief you know these these these
actors really gave me while i was there
was just very helpful and
you know executing the performance that
i think we all wanted to give
i know that you wouldn't have actually
stolen anything from set but
hypothetically
did you borrow anything and it's now
still in your home
uh are you gonna snitch can you tell
um there is something i got i don't
wanna say what
but i got something
i unfortunately could not get away with
the crime
yeah custom she was going back to africa
so like the customs probably
yeah be like man to the side please
okay i won't pressure you to ask what's
in was it gifted you did you
actually borrow it what you doing right
now stephen what you trying to do man
who are you stephen you work for the
movie it works i'm not saying that i
work for amazon today
but hypothetically a gift it was a gift
i got some gifts i think um you know
gifts from
departments from the movie like we all
took something back
you know otherwise people want to
believe me
i understand this is going to be my last
question because i'm just about out of
time
i'm a big fan of ruth carter and uh she
just does such a great job with costumes
i'm curious for each of you to talk a
little bit about working with her and
like
just working with ruth because she's so
good she's such a
big kid you know what i mean like she
she loves what she does
and i think you need that when you're
doing a job like this
we forget we're building worlds we're
building we're
we're using our imagination she's used
every ounce of her imagination to build
such
an amazing line of wardrobe for this
this movie and like it added so much
without her we we couldn't have
added those layers to what makes this
you know zamunda and next dory are so
different
and like you know everybody had their
everyone's clothes were so different
every pattern was different she took so
much
attention it was she's just a master of
what she does
and it was great to be a part of what to
just wear something that she made man
she's amazing
rumor has it that she's going to receive
her star
on the hollywood walk of fame which is
so well deserved
so so well deserved ruth potter is not
only just
a a a costume designer she's a historian
there's so much history that she knows
there's so much research that she does
she is a master at her craft and her
skill
she is truly
pun intended a cut from a different
thread
congrats on the movie and thank you so
much for giving me your time
no problem stephen have a good one man
thank you